il aime buzzati alec castonguay
christian dufour bonsoir bonsoir
hélène est ce que je vous présente
désormais chroniqueuse pour les clubs de
l'information donc le soleil le droit
etc
alors bravo vous avez signé une
chronique à toutes les semaines à toutes
les semaines à partir de la semaine
prochaine bah bravo et on est content de
toute façon de vous garder
et puis parlons des de ses voyages gens
qui reviennent bout du compte de parler
des voyages à qui rien fait depuis les
vacances de noël crise y en a souvent
parlé ensemble qu'on se dise
épouvantable l'atelier reviennent le
problème c'est que ces lots avant la
ligne pour réserver un hôtel alors on
écoute pierre paul-hus et sur rodriguez
qui répondent les voyageurs qui revient
le canada attend de 20 à 30 heures pour
essayer de réserver un hôtel qui
regroupe la quarantaine mais ils sont
incapables de joindre personne c'est
vraiment le bordel
est ce qu'il promet un aspect l'odeur
tâte 4s qui compte régler le problème
desautels certaines des mesures les plus
strictes au monde vous savez les vols
dans le sud où était suspendu et j'adore
passer des tests à l'arrivée ya des
quarantaines dans les différents hôtels
je demanderai aux conservateurs
d'arrêter d'essayer de faire par
l'ensemble des québécois et l'ensemble
des canadiens ont fait notre job
alors tour de table on voulait les clous
et presse au pilori on l'est on a parlé
contre la les conservateurs disent mais
là c'est pas gentil on les fait à temps
de trajet que vous en pensez il faut dit
pourtant de la situation là c'est quand
même ils ont l'air un peu désorganisé
l'autre cette ligne ne suffisent pas à
la demande
en coulisses on vous dit qu'on travaille
beaucoup là-dessus
ce que je comprends c'est qu'il y aurait
seulement quelques dizaines de
téléphonistes le chiffre de 60 à peu
près circulent donc 60 téléphonique pour
répondre aux appels de tout le monde
évidemment ce n'est pas suffisant et
surtout ce qu'on me dit c'est que cette
ligne est devenu une sorte de déversoir
l'espèce de ligne à laquelle tout le
monde a appelé pour avoir des
informations sur seulement pour faire
des réservations au tél
donc là on pense à ajouter des
téléphonistes peut-être ajouter même des
fonctionnaires fédéraux sur les lignes
pour faire des tri entre ceux qui
veulent des renseignements et ceux qui
veulent réserver pour essayer que ça
aille plus vite
éventuellement d'instaurer un site web
aussi pour qu'on puisse faire ses
réservations au lent à l'émeute est même
directement avec les hôtels sans passer
par cette ligne regretté denis american
express mais en coulisses aussi on dit
où l on vous l'avait dit qu on vous
l'avait dit pas partir parce que les
choses pourraient survenir
voilà c'est alec c'est compliqué puis
j'étais un peu prévisible sur les
lettres
oui mais en même temps on annonce si
cette mesure à la fin du mois de janvier
après au moins dix jours de réflexion
pour que ça rentre en vigueur trois
semaines plus tard et on se disait bon
ils prennent leur temps pour que ce soit
bien ficelé un parce que c'est complet
qui va avoir du monde faut que ça
fonctionne
alors autant qu'à prendre son temps on
comprend au moins ça va fonctionner mais
ça fonctionne pas et on a quand même
pris son temps pour le mettre en place
me semble-t-il que c'était prévisible
qu'une ligne téléphonique comme dans le
bon vieux viiie siècle ça suffirait pas
à la demande qu'on devrait travailler
sur quelque chose d'un peu plus
automatisée avec des sites internet
mais non on les gouvernements encore
réfléchi dans le mauvais siècle et on se
retrouve avec un embouteillage
je dis pas que c'est pas entièrement de
leur faute mais je m
on a quand même pris du temps pour
l'annoncer on a quand même voulu bien
faire les choses et on n'est pas arrivé
je consomme petit peu en s'entraînant en
tant qu'ancien christian ben je trouve
pas c'est étonnant parce qu'une
politique publique qui repose en partie
sur la démagogie pour produire notre de
l'hystérie à l'égard de quelqu'un qu'on
aime à l'heure d'aller à l'étranger qui
sont devenus comme les boucs émissaires
de la peur collective vois ça m'étonne
pas en fait que ça marche pas
heureusement d'hystérie semble
s'atténuer un petit transfert sur le
pape comme décidément la semaine passée
et je pense de plus en plus de canadiens
vont réaliser que hôtesse avant de
quitter un pays étranger un texte en
arrivant à l'aréoport plus une vraie
quarantaine en fait surveiller plus un
troisième test ça suffit sauf que séjour
à l'hôtel je fais pas la route pour
n'est pas la nouvelle zélande
le représentant du gouvernement a dit
qu'on avait les mesures les plus
strictes au creusement dans le monde
justement c'est exagéré et on sait que
des canadiens qui ont laissé contester
ces mesures leur disant que c'était
punitives à l'égard des citoyens qui
n'ont pas contrevenu à la loi
et moi je crois que si les tribunaux en
fait annuler ces mesures-là se fera l
affaire du gouvernement se fera l
affaire de justin trudeau à mon avis est
fait fort c'est là mais là dessus et ça
ne marche pas c'est exagéré sur moi
c'est pas le pays - le canada s'est pas
l'image du canada que j'ai actuellement
trois tests une vraie quarantaine s'est
pas assez pendant au plus sait-on que
factuellement il faut dire alec hélène
que le canada s'est hissé parmi les pays
les plus sévères
par exemple si on exclut les deux ou
trois exceptions on est parmi les pays
les plus sévères là dessus le avec oui
sans aucun doute
et christian raison dit que déjà
énormément de mesures en place et oui
gouvernement s'est fait forcer la main
par la pression populaire mais aussi par
la pression politique du gouvernement
legault qui dans au mois de janvier
mais énormément de pression pour que ça
bouge du côté du gouvernement fédéral
on est arrivé même avec une situation de
compromis certains voulaient que ce soit
14 jours superviser l hôtel là on est
trois jours
en attendant le test positif ou négatif
si c'est négatif on peut retourner à la
maison
c'était déjà un compromis par rapport à
ce que certains souhaitaient oui on a
déjà on a déjà eu effectivement des
mesures très sévères en place parce que
hélas ne vous dit puis alex si ils ont
eu du temps de jeu préparé mais c'est un
peu quelqu'un qui se dit ils sont fait
tirer l'oreille un peu pour aller
jusqu'à la fosse et c'est clair c'est
clair mais je suis totalement d'accord
le gouvernement fédéral ne voulait pas
rhj est ce qu'on comprend entre les
lignes c'est que même les conseils la de
la santé publique qu'il ne conseillait
pas nécessairement dans les cendres dans
cette direction on nous rappelait
toujours que les contaminations
provenant des voyages étaient deux le
petit contributeur à la à l'éclosion
gêner les temps les contacts radio
communautaire donc chassé dakar qui se
scinde ici jamais au tribunal devait
l'évacuer
je pas certaine que tu avais serais très
mécontent travail ce qui m'amène à notre
sujet on va passer sur les écoles parce
qu'on aime et on va aller sur les avis
de la santé publique parce que vous
dites
la santé publique ne reconnais ne
recommandait pas nécessairement d'aller
aussi loin et là on est et depuis début
de cette crise là on est devant la
situation où les gouvernants reçoivent
des avis parfois divergents de la la
santé publique parfois divergents ils
savent paul docteur de serre nous attend
on le sait pas lire
bien sûr qu'on est prudent il faut être
prudent mais on ne le sais tu pas bref
divergent et ils prennent des décisions
il ya eu des avis vendredi qui ont été
rendus publics je veux votre avis
là-dessus
est ce que vous trouvez ça épouvantable
ou graves ou ou est ce que c'est une
histoire qu'on n'a pas suivi à la lettre
les avis la santé publique chance avec
vous avec le cinéma par exemple ou sur
le restera pardon ou la santé publique
était plus lent ne rien laisser passer
plus pour le québec
moi y'a rien qui m'a sauté aux yeux
comme étant
matic dans ce qui a été rendu public on
peut s'accrocher ici et là certaines
choses mais y avait rien de
particulièrement dramatique pourquoi
parce que je pense que ce qui aurait été
le plus de dommages à pour le
gouvernement sait s'il y en avait fait -
qu'est-ce que la santé publique réclamée
donc si la santé publique 10ème voici ce
qu on doive parce qu'on a besoin pour
protéger la population que le
gouvernement dise non pour des raisons
économiques je garde ce ouvert aux
garçons
au contraire il ya certaines faut la
santé publique n'hésitez était pas
certaine d'y aller les restaurants qu'on
les garde ouvert pour les bulles
familiale ou non un peu plus longtemps
puis le rendement du bain par souci de
cohérence au moment donné les gens s'y
perdre vont super doux si on est pour
les fermer dans une semaine mais aussi
bien pour les rouvrir alors il ya des
décisions qui ont été très politique et
c'est normal ceux qui sont élus pour
prendre des décisions là mais si on
avait fait l'inversé qu'on n'avait pas
suivi des recommandations à la baisse là
je pense qu un beaucoup plus de bon vous
dites c'est normal mais christian on
entend souvent des bandes oui mais
pourquoi ils ne suivent pas que la
science comme si la science est un une
voix tracy blanche très clair à suivre
c'est pas si simple que ça christian non
c'est pas si simple europe ça me choque
pas en soi que le dernier mot sur le
premier ministre qu'il est ce que dit ce
qui ressort c'est quand même la
responsabilité du premier ministre le
bon dans la façon dont on a vécu
confinement au québec parce que monsieur
legault au fond sa priorité kg nasa a
été beaucoup d écoles puis l'économie
mais il reste que pour suivi des
recommandations de la santé plus dans
des domaines qui sont plus liés à la
culture à la joie de vivre plaisir et
moi je critique ce gouvernement je
trouve que le confinement québec a été
trop austère trop bien pensants parce
que les deux principales mesures qui
nous ont frappés ou le gouvernement pas
suivi les recommandations de la santé
publique ont accosté pas droit comme
berceau de la stratégie c'était les
restaurants les thérapies cinéma et
c'était le couvre-feu aussi donc c'est
normal c'est prévisible que les cdm on
voit que quand même eu un choix de
monsieur legault un peu austère moi je
trouve
hélène sur ce sujet la dichotomie entre
la science santé publique et la
gouvernance politique de l'eau ouais ben
en fait je suis entièrement d'accord
avec mes deux collègues allée en deçà
des zi de la santé publique aurait été
dommageable à l'est aussi on peut
simplement passer pour et les dires va
peut-être qu'on voit juste faire en
sorte que les choses vont se régler plus
rapidement
et par ailleurs vous l'avait bien dit la
science elle aussi par tonne elle
apprend au fur et à mesure il ya des
choses qu'on découvre donc et la science
est importante elle ni guide
mais en ce moment la science ne sait pas
tout est donc ils et voilà quand même
assez normal que les politiques puissent
s'en écarter légèrement pour des raisons
politiques écrits de françois legault du
cham dit sur facebook on a parlé de
gaulle dans l'ain perfetti l'a relu les
mémoires pas les mémoires mais la
biographie de gaulle écrit par alain
peyrefitte ancien collaborateur mines
etc
et là il dit les français ont besoin
d'avoir il cite de god
les français ont besoin d'avoir
l'orgueil de la france sinon il se
traîne dans la médiocrité
ils se disputent ils prennent le
raccourci vers le bistrot fin de la
citation de de gaulle alors legault qui
s'inspire de gaulle pour son
nationalisme de fierté à christian web
ont marqué moi je trouve ça un peu
normal et j'aime bien ça le fait que le
premier ministre legault qui doit se
sentir très seul
en fait dans la gestion de ce drame la
main comme réflexe en fait d'aller vers
les grands anciens c'est à dire de lire
une biographie du général de gaulle donc
et pas n'importe qui qui est un
francophone aussi mais dans la mesure où
évidemment où il confond pas les
français que les québécois puissent pas
trop pour de gaulle encore mais assez
sympathique souley que monsieur legault
s'est ainsi fait pas gérer la pandémie
viol une biographie du général de gaulle
alec chose tout à fait correct que
françois legault utilisent facebook les
samedis s'il veut passer des messages
parfois ils sont est axée sur le court
terme par exemple lorsqu'on avait là le
débat la semaine dernière sur les
libertés d'académique la liberté
d'expression dans les écoles c'est un
sujet qui était dans les universités
sochaux qui était brûlant il a décidé de
l'aborder le c'était plutôt samedi sur
le nationalisme quelque chose d'un peu
plus historique
une droite c'est parlant sur le genre de
national est qu'ils le lèvent leur
poussée de fierté il dit c'est important
de ce sentiment là que je veux faire
reconnaît enfin que je me bouge c'est au
québec ce samedi quelque chose quant aux
et puis c'est l'une des lignes de force
de son mandat il me le répéter souvent
en entrevue que l'inde est l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles il est revenu en
politique c'était pour mousser ce
nationalisme la fierté d'être québécois
il ya beaucoup de ces gestes identitaire
d'ailleurs qui vont dans ce sens là donc
ils si peu martelé ce sujet là il va le
faire parce que c'était une un marqueur
la différence pour lui par rapport à
d'autres partis politiques notamment le
parti libéral pour la prochaine campagne
électorale donc c'est sûr qu'il va le
ramener sur le tapis assez régulièrement
d'ici la fin de son mandat très bien
j'étais discipline et vous avez été
disciplinés pas moi mais votre sur le
génocide ouigours hélène je commence
avec vous débord vote à la chambre des
communes les conservateurs sont pour
qu'on appelle donc ce qui se passe
actuellement en chine un génocide le
bloc également le npd et les libéraux il
y aura un vote libre expliquez moi ou on
s'en va avec ça eh bien il ya eu un vote
ce soir est en fait si le silence est
effectivement doré ben le message était
très clair ce soir donc tous les
libéraux qui ont voté ont voté eux aussi
avec l'opposition pour dire c'est un
génocide ce qui se passe mais toute la
banquette ministériel elle était absente
on envoyait un seul ministre monsieur
garneau aux affaires étrangères pour
dire qu'il s'abstenait
et d'ailleurs il y avait la crau à la
procédure parlementaire en disant qu'il
s'abstenait au nom du gouvernement ceux
qui lui ont été d'ailleurs reproché mais
c'est clairement un message
donc c'est un message codé envoyé à
l'endroit de la chine donc
officiellement le gouvernement
les pauvres n'est pas en faveur de la
reconnaissance du génocide
mais on l'est tous nos libéraux voter en
faveur de l'opération alors lisez entre
les lignes
évidemment c'est parce qu'on veut pas
s'aliéner la chaîne la chine avec la
question des 2 maicon madame a pas de
front en tout cas 30 secondes
l'aic et christian allex on était dans
une situation un peu complexe pour le
gouvernement parce qu'on voudrait bien
envoyé le message mais comme le dylan
ont une relation tellement tendue avec
la chine vous avez vu la sortie d'
ambassadeur chinois tahoua en fait
semaine qu'ils aimaient les vous pas de
nos affaires c'est de l'ingérence dans
les affaires internes de la chine donc
on a quand même encore effectivement les
deux mascottes sont emprisonnés la boxe
tout une relation aussi a commencé à
reconstruire avec la chine donc on est
allé aussi loin qu'on pouvait j'ai ôté
de la bouée du côté des banques est au
ministère en conclusion quelques
secondes le silence assourdissant des
chefs de gouvernements musulmans des
gens comme erdogan en turquie chez sap
aux draps parlent mais moi ça me fera
beaucoup cette terre et parce que cette
petite nation musulmane nos vies et les
états musulmans 2 10.20 merci à vous
trois très intéressant merci beaucoup au
revoir à voir